hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just check it in on you
sorry sounded bad to me see you now you
Thursday's go and I know that there is
some happy people in the District of
Columbia and some unbelievable dist
unbelievably disappointed fans in
Houston Texas what of [__] series
first time ever seven-game series the
road team won every [__] game
unbelievable
this series go [__] yourself to that
what a crazy goddamn series I mean I'll
tell you right now you got to think the
[__] Nationals win the first two
games in Houston then they got three in
a [__] row at home you think of [__]
they're gonna be up well at least three
to possibly wrapping up in their own
[__] building and they dropped the
next three at home demoralizing to a
team that wanted only two years earlier
knows how to [__] win has l2v they
got the Mojo going you think they gonna
drop forward a [__] row they're gonna
wrap it up Game six
Nationals come out give him the old
right there Fred and [__] Game six
and then I love Game seven Astros came
back out with their swagger they were up
to - nothing it was their [__] game
it seemed like they rose to the goddamn
occasion and then I don't know what the
[__] happens I was kind of watching my
kid and then when I saw the second home
run which I thought tied it up I didn't
know it was a 2-run shot or was the
first one a 2-run shot I don't know I
was doing daddy duty I did like nine Ric
Flair's in a row whoa
my wife was upstairs what's going on I
[__] tied up
I was like no they're up by one then
they got the insurance runs then they
had the one two three [__] inning in
the ninth inning and that was just
[__] over over and every inning it
seemed the Astros had one or two guys on
base and some other Nationals would get
out of it who the [__] would have
thought then for some reason Bryce
Harper gets a ton of [__] I don't
understand that
like what he had to do with anything the
man was nice enough to go make somebody
else spend three hundred million dollars
on him you guys won a World Series there
was no reason to say mean [__] to him he
had nothing to do with it you know he's
a great player you know dick didn't
going after Bryce Harper really say more
about you than it did about him you know
[__] you [__] let people [__] you dad
mom's bang that [__]
and I never thought EXO congratulations
to the Washington Nationals / Montreal
Expos there's got to be a few Montreal
fans up there that we're happy but we're
also shedding a few tears some legit
baseball fans the five or six of them up
there
don't worry I believe the Tampa Bay
Devil Rays sorry Rays don't want to piss
it off any Jesus freaks up in Montreal
might be coming your way I don't know
what's going on I don't know what's
going on in tamp I think they just you
know if it's not [__] that grapefruit
grapefruit league horseshit they don't
care about it because Tampa Bay Rays it
consistently almost from the beginning
have just been a quality product to go
down and see but I just think there's
too many people that relocated Florida
you know it's like la la notoriously
loses football teams and baseball teams
and all of this [__] it's just because
that's just the weather is just too
goddamn nice and there's too many
transplant people that are just like can
you believe it 60 degrees in January and
then he'd just go outside nobody cares
and the only reason why the Lakers draw
is because so many [__] celebrities
show up everybody wants to go down and
see who's sitting courtside texting and
not [__] paying attention Oh a
Celtics fan
he's a still a Celtics fan got a trash
that I won't [__] with you they have
a good fan base but it's all at the top
of the arena for the most part I don't
know but what I'm really starting to
find is you know this guy wrote this
whole article about the guy carrying the
bat down to first base I saw you know
Gary from the Howard Stern Show tweeted
something which I actually agreed with
and I just think the game has just
changed and it's kind of like how I
don't go to I would I would never go to
a [__] like nah nightclub you know at
my age I wouldn't do that because it's
not my time anymore it's this is young
people's time this is their music don't
be that creepy guy in the corner that's
weird and everybody out and everybody's
looking over like oh that a cop does
that guy owned this place was anybody
watching my drink when I went to the
bathroom that guy was a little too close
to my glass you don't want to be that
guy I just think it's just a [__]
different time because how guys my age
view all of this over celebrating in
self congratulatory horseshit young
people seem to love it so who the [__]
are we to say that you know that it's
wrong I don't know I look just as an old
guy looking at it it's like
cringe-worthy [__] behavior I and I
don't think that it's genuine you're not
genuinely celebrating you just did
something positive and you know it's
gonna be on SportsCenter so now you got
to do the Macarena or pretend to be
rowing a boat or whatever [__] stupid
thing that they're doing my favorite
thing is when when a quarterback which
should not even allowed to hit anymore
literally like an offensive lineman can
be tackling you and you fall into just
above his knees
and it's called roughing the [__]
past my thing that was when the [__]
douche is scrambling runs six yards for
a first down the linebacker a cornerback
could totally drill him but then has to
pull up and then the guy sides in like
he's playing softball and then
immediately pops up it [__] does the
first down [__] thing that I mean
even as a young person you don't think
that's a little ridiculous don't hit him
don't hit him then he stands up like we
don't meanwhile it's 10 to 3 in the
second quarter I don't buy it
I don't but it's your time now so
[__] you know you want to watch
people reenact 98° is [__] dance
moves after they score a touchdown to
make it 17 16 I mean I guess that's what
the [__] it is now I have to be honest
with you
I'm fighting it because I don't know
what I'm gonna do if I stop watching
sports but I'm just starting to like
like an old man like when there's like I
don't know well I don't know what
happens they just tear down everything
and build something made out of glass
and you don't recognize anything anymore
and you just kind of got to be like well
I guess it's over I guess it's over so I
think it's it's kind of over for me I
can't believe I'm saying this I still
enjoy the game the game will always be
the game I just don't know they should
have like a [__] you know they never
show the fights anymore in hockey they
try to they pan away from it or they
takes on now a fight is broke it out you
like show it and they [__] just it
takes them forever to get over there
they should have like a [__] old man
NFL Sunday and this right after somebody
gains you know 2.8 yards to make it you
know second and seven point
two in the person gets up and starts
doing whatever the [__] they're gonna do
I think they should just go to like a
test pattern and it just goes bad it up
but I haven't added in it except it's
music form I don't know the 60 70s and
80s yeah because I I got all excited
they said that that that [__] guy in
B band the other guy some other Center
had a fight and I put it on they just
like they just put each other in
headlocks there was no there was no
fight
I could have survived what either one of
them did to the other guy he just
grabbed me by my big Falana I'm actually
half this size let's not get crazy bill
you're 51 but you know what I mean I was
like you know so it'd be even [__]
so-and-so had an actual fight not one I
know what do I know I'm a [__] old
man what do I know I don't I don't know
anything so I think I don't know this is
a good time to leave to Boston's won all
these [__] titles it's never gonna
get better than this right Brady's gonna
be gone and probably the next six years
at some point he's gonna retire I should
just [__] walk away you know I mean
think about am I really having a good
time all I do is [__] about it now I go
to games in the [__] music is playing
during the goddamn game yeah you used to
call me all yourself right sitting there
going like Jesus Christ I need [__]
earplugs this is an outdoor stadium and
I need earplugs not from the crowd
cheering from the [__] DJ music being
played and I just think like you know
something I remember a long time ago
seeing that great Eagle player on NFL
Films in the 1980s and they asked him
hey when you watch a football game today
how do you fit he just goes you wouldn't
watch your football game today just
[__] flipped out and I remember as a
young person laughing like what the [__]
is wrong with this guy you don't like
watch and Dan Marino whatever but he was
older and he came up and a three yards
in a cloud of dust
you could clothesline people and
everything so he thought everybody in
the 80s were a bunch of [__] so now
I've become that guy and rather than
further embarrass myself you know
sitting on my front lawn and by the way
young people someday you will have a
front lawn and you won't put on people
on it okay when you own the debt on that
piece of property and realize that
there's no way you're ever gonna make
money off of this [__] thing and that
bankers actually control everything
you're gonna be a little salty when some
little [__] comes up on your [__]
yard - we'll see we'll see every
generation thinks they're gonna let the
kids play in their yard it's not about
the kids it's about you know what it's
about today's Halloween and it's about
that [__] time when kids show up to
the door with that punk-ass look on
their face knowing that they're too old
to be trick-or-treating and thinking
you're too stupid to realize what's
going on one of my favorite [__]
things one of my favorite [__] things
and this year I think I'm finally just
gonna say I don't care what they do to
my shrubs I'm just gonna be like I'm not
giving you candy you're too old I mean
you're almost as tall as I am your voice
your balls have dropped you got to get
the but I couldn't say that then right
because then he would [__] Instagram
from the house oh my god me and my
friend were just trying to
trick-or-treat and this guy not only did
he not give us candy
hashtag humbug um he pre-talk tabat my
testicles you know so there you go young
people hit homeruns stand there and
admire them because the next that guy
can't get thrown at because everybody's
gonna get a warning and skip around you
know what I think you should do now now
you have to take it to the next level
generation Z I think when you hit a home
run you carry the bat
down to the first baseline and then you
start twirling it like a baton as you
high step to second base
alright then you take your head off
between second and third you know for
all the troops that sacrifice so you
could twirl your bat between first and
second base and then you I don't you tie
off your shirt for transpeople I guess
on the way to home plate you know and
then you do the piece you look up to God
because it is all about God it's not
about you anyway that's why I like
hockey
I've always liked hockey anyways but I
mean what's great about hockey is the
game moves too fast for all the
Millennials and generation Z's to be
moonwalking every time they make a good
pass or get an assist or whatever the
[__] you would celebrate in hockey I
mean I don't know okay Jesus Christ even
that seemed too long to me but all right
let's move ahead here by the way I got
one for you
this is all just you know I'm just gonna
rebrand this whole podcast it's just
[__] old man [__] you know speaking
of Halloween this is the first year make
get to take my daughter out you know
trick-or-treating and I'm gonna go old
school I'm gonna tell her not to do a
celebratory dance when the candy gets
put in the bag and I'm gonna teach her
to look the person in the eye and say
thank you and then that's gonna be it
you know and someday when she when she
turns 10 I'm gonna be like alright I
think that you're a little too old for
this
Halloween's for the kids you're not a
kid anymore alright you can be driving
in six years quit your crying quit your
crying is that to mean my mighty [__]
no he scores a touchdown to make it
forty eight to six and oh my god he's
he's reenacting okay you go like I own
your team like this let's just fine
alright pill
now that you've pitched for nine weeks
in a row about this [__] what are you
gonna do about it are you gonna stop
watching how about I think I'm gonna
swim Brady retires I'll stop can i bail
I don't think I don't have anything else
in my life what would I do I think I'm
gonna go to college sports cuz it seems
to be less there's less of that you know
maybe they're doing the math on how much
they just got paid to hit that one home
run or catch that touchdown pass or
slide over the first down marker I don't
know what the [__] it is oh here's one
for you bill why don't you reach out to
the people you make it fun of I
explained to me how it is not how it is
genuinely celebrating when you've worked
out a celebration with another teammate
I dive just out of curiosity how it's
not in the moment losing your [__]
mind that type of [__] you know oh I
can't get off this topic people
oh they're hitting a double game 111 in
the middle of the season and you're
eight games out and you look over at the
bench and you do the holster in the
[__] bowl thing oh is that why you're
not even in [__] the playoff
contention I hit a double well this is
what we do is pretend miming stirring
some oatmeal in a bowl that really gets
everybody going we seem to see the
curveball more sorry
yeah it's please don't even write it I
don't give a [__] I really don't give a
[__] it's just all reminding me of that
I'm old it has nothing to do with you
guys it has nothing to do with the fact
that you grew up with [__]
smartphones and you can't stop taking
pictures of yourselves that it's cause
you'd be the most self-involved [__]
human beings I've ever seen it's like
it's not enough you hit a home run and
there's 60,000 people standing up
chanting your [__] name it's not
enough there has to be another level
of me I'm going for a record here Oh
going for what oh my god here
seven elmo's 18 minutes of old man
ranting I know this whole thing's gonna
be reduced the young people on any level
do you know what I'm talking about
anything on any level that's why I like
that Leonard guy did you see the other
night when that [__] guy how do you
know what he did he got a rebound shook
a guy off and then he dunks the ball and
he hangs on the rim and starts [__]
[__] the air he's like pelvic pumping
I just can't imagine you sitting there
with your son daddy what's he doing he's
miming [__] the other team in the ass
son cuz he scored two points in the
second quarter
what he's doing by Miami [__] the
other team in the ass is he's indicating
that they are his [__] I believe it's a
prison thing or just a type-a alpha male
bravado thing I don't know all right hey
hey can we get it cuz let's talk about
some music shall we as always I've been
butchering the [__] drums actually
you know a long time ago I picked up
guitar I started playing I was getting
like halfway decent and then I did one
of many repairs on my house and there
was [__] too many repair men were in
the house every day and I sucked so bad
I was too self-conscious to keep playing
like I would like I would play like
really quietly not through the amp just
all embarrassed breathing and dust as
they were working in the other room you
know it was just something you know he
had guys in your house fixing [__] and
I'm in the I'm in the other room with
the ukulele dad did it did it was just I
just I couldn't get past how ridiculous
I must look to them so I just sort of
stopped
and then I kind of forgot everything
that I knew when I went back to pick it
up afterwards and I got frustrated well
I picked it back up again and I just
started learning some Judas Priest riffs
heading out to the highway and I really
forgot how [__] great that band was
is whatever you want to say and but
anyways I finally figured out how to
play I'm starting to get my doubles
remembering that little asian girl who
absolutely crushed the [__] good
times bad times [__] I was just like how
the [__] did she get i've been
practicing like four times the amount of
time she's been on earth and she and she
got there before me
she's like eight years old when did she
start playing three four I mean I I mean
your feet got to be able to touch the
pedals it's unbelievable so inspired by
her here's a good song if you're an old
white dude like me then you'll [__]
trying to get you doubles up to speed
here's something positive no old man
bitching Michael Jackson's want to be
starting something just play along to
that until your foot falls off and play
along to it everyday and then one day
you'll just have the stamina to do that
and then go back and try to play good
times bad times at about 80 BPM s and I
think you'll be surprised you'll still
be like 13 away but you'll be a lot
closer all right let me read a little
advertising here all right you know it
and when I got up to 80 BPM I was by
myself and I did a little celebratory
dance I think that's the equivalent to
being you know down 10 to 3 in the
second quarter and you catch a pass for
a first down and then [__] do a
10-second celebration dance
I think the equivalent to that is me
playing good times bad times at 80 BPM s
still 13 BPMS away I'm still down by
seven and I'm gonna get up off the drum
still do a little [__] moonwalk have
I ever been more unlikable on a podcast
I know there's a bunch of old guys going
yes exactly all right when it comes to
meat butcher box everybody when it comes
to me quality meats there's more there's
more to it than texture and taste
not everyone has convenient access to
high-quality meat every month butcher
block ships a curated selection of high
quality meat right to my home all meat
is free of antibiotics and an e and
added hormones each box has nine to
eleven pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meals packed fresh and
shipped frozen in vacuum sealed so it
stays that way you can customize your
own box or go I'll go with one of theirs
either way you get exactly what you want
it's the best meat ship right to my door
which means one less trip to the grocers
well what if I want a side dish it's
like I go to the grocery store just to
buy meat and then I go I would say it's
it's less heavy bags to the grocery
store right options like 100% grass-fed
and finished beef free-range organic
chicken my favorite right here heritage
breed pork wild caught Alaskan salmon
you don't know what and sugar nitrates
sugar / nitrate free bacon with
Thanksgiving right around the corner now
is the perfect time to give butcher box
to try sign up today and get a free
turkey plus $20 off your first box just
go to butcher box com / / or enter the
promo code burette check out that's
butcher bucks com / / or enter promo
code bir at checkout for a free turkey
free turkey at $20 and $20 off your
first box this spot year turkey for
thanksgiving that's like somebody buying
you a [__] Christmas tree for
Christmas all right let's get to
something positive here did anybody see
dolomite is my name starring Eddie
Murphy I cannot recommend that movie
enough it's one of Eddie's greatest
performances it's such a positive
uplifting movie and in the
it's dedicated in the memory of Eddie's
brother Charlie and which was incredible
to me cuz I was watched when I was
watching that movie I remembered I
learned who Dolomites was through
Charlie Murphy when we were on the rich
[__] Chappelle's Show tour that donnell
rawlings put together way back in the
day and he made a reference to dolomite
and I said who's that and he goes I'm
have charges man you don't know a little
[__] dolomite is and I was just like no
and he starts you know telling me all
the stories about him is doing all the
[__] five minute rhymes and all of
this [__] I remember it was almost like
upset with me cuz [__] you bill you
don't know about dolomite and all that
[__] so I read all of this stuff I guess
you know Charlie used to take Eddie to
the coast see those movies and then I
found a clip on YouTube after I listen I
listen to one of the clips from eat out
more I think it was his first dolomite
first comedy album and there's a clip
it's like a six minute like bit where it
rhymes this guy's playing you know music
in the background and it's like six
[__] I don't know how many times
you'd have to listen to it to memorize
it but like all these years later
Charlie was on some radio show and he
just did it word for [__] word and he
sounded just like him
and I don't know it was such a cool like
full circle thing to think oh my god
that's what he was talking about and
that's why he's giving me [__] this is
how much this guy meant to him and that
you know and he was such a great
storyteller and all of that and I don't
know just watching that movie and seeing
this guy that nobody wanted to hire and
he was and he just [__] just did it
all himself like we can't sell this
record it's too dirty I [__] that guy
I'll do it myself
just made him in his apartment sold them
out on the street it's gonna make a
movie [__] you we don't want your movie
had he had to [__] put up all the
money for his movie all of that [__]
it's what's amazing is that's the same
way this businesses today you know I had
a buddy of mine you know going through
the [__] ups and downs of this
business and I was just talking about
that I was just like you know it's one
of those deals like we are not ever
gonna be the flavor of the month no
one's looking for a bald redheaded male
and nobody's looking for you so we're
just gonna have to generate our own [__]
and I'm whatever business if you listen
to this whatever business you're in I'm
sure it's the same way that is the best
bet the best bet in the world is that
you're gonna have to [__] do it but I
can't I cannot tell you what a [__]
great movie that was and it was such a
[__] positive positive movie and Eddie
was absolutely hilarious and I don't
know it was just you know he hasn't put
out a movie in a little bit right it
took a few years off or something like
that it was great to see him in
something like this I don't know why I
wish he would do more stuff like this
it's [__] amazing incredible movie
Dolomites is my name so there you go I
started off negative right started off
[__] negative and IA ended positive
and you know what's funny I was actually
when I was watching Dolomites and he
talks all kinds of crazy [__] and I was
watching the crowd like laughing about
it then I was thinking like is this an
extension of is this an extension of
that all this extra celebrating impel
Vic pumping maybe that's what it is
maybe I don't get it I don't know I
don't know what it is but like I don't
know when you dunk a ball to make it
[__] 38:34 yeah hanging on the rim
and there's kids in the crowd like
comedians get all this [__] this guy's
literally
[__] the air he's already 9 feet tall
so his dicks in everybody's eye level
now he's [__] like now they're
looking at his undercarriage [__] I
just don't get it all right I'm sorry
explain it to me I'm old and I'm scared
I don't know what things mean anymore
there I admit took me a half an hour I
finally admitted it okay I admitted that
I'm a scared old man okay kid young
people can you admit on some level that
it is a little [__] just you know not
about the team it's kind of about you in
that moment maybe just a little bit I
don't know all right that is the podcast
Jesus Christ that way I just want to let
you guys know that was as uncomfortable
for me as it probably was for you to
listen to I really hate being the
[__] old guy coming down on the
youngsters but jesus [__] christ you
know I like sports - can you dial it
down just a little bit how about every
other time you gain 3 yards you do the
moonwalk back to the huddle can we do
that pass interference roughing the
passer there's a hell of a fight
breaking out that you're not gonna see
on the ice where things aren't the way
they used to be all right please enjoy
the music everybody oh by the way thank
you everybody once again for coming out
to the for the live podcast recording
which is I really wish I did the whole
[__] celebrating in sports thing
because then young people could have
[__] been yelling at me we could add
a nice debate maybe I'll do that next
time because I had such a good time
doing the live podcast that I feel like
I don't know like I might want to be
doing another one maybe in a city that
isn't Los Angeles I don't know I don't
know we'll have to figure something out
I'm thinking Vegas I'm thinking if I do
my show Saturday night in Vegas and then
Sunday
maybe I do a podcast and then [__]
Monday I go to the the [__] Vegas
nights games people I'm not gonna stop
watching sports I got nothing else
that's all I got
okay I'm sorry that's all I got
alright listen to the music enjoy your
week your [__] and I'll check in on now
you're not cut I'm on the cut today
alright I got no one to blame but myself
I'll take this loss enjoy the music and
then we got to throw back thirty minutes
of a Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcasts from a
few years ago last week and I'm out with
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
October 31st 2011
I apologize podcasts up being so goddamn
late I recorded one yesterday this is
really becoming a theme every week I
just apologized these last couple of
[__] weeks has just been brutal I've
been overseas I've had those problems
and this week I came back east doing the
Jimmy Fallon show today I actually get
to sit down and do panel like a big shot
[__] you [__] god damn it you're gonna
give up a [__] field goal right here
at the end why would you ever bet money
on the [__] San Diego Chargers cuz
anybody tell me what what the [__] is
wrong with me
Jesus Christ can somebody out there who
has some sort of a football mind just
explain to me the prevent defense yeah
give him a 20-yard cushion yeah there
you go well we we don't want to give it
all up but what is wrong with this
[__] oh god this is gonna be one of
these [__] weeks you know I already
recorded a podcast Joe sent me the file
it was too goddamn big he's out for the
night with the lady so now I have to
record another one you know like like I
have any funny left and now for some
reason these stupid cords are acting up
this is one of the challenge you guys to
find a podcast out there that has as
many listeners as mine that is still
this [__] pathetically low-rent you
know I feel like I'm in like that band
that's just never gonna make it like you
know with 20 years in we're still riding
in a van like the anvil story it's just
[__] brutal all right whatever so you
know what you guys get to podcast this
week cuz when old Twinkle Toes the teen
idol sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program gets back from his hot little
date with a little tall drink of water
that little number you met at the
pictures I'll also post that one and
hopefully that one will be of better
quality than this one although I don't
know we recorded it on his iPhone
so anyways I'm sitting here in a hotel
room by myself and I've already taped
Jimmy Fallon show obviously the fact
that I brought it up it went great and
I'm sure some of you [__] will watch it
and tell me that you didn't think it was
great but you know what I don't need you
I don't need anybody actually I do I
need somebody right now I'm thinking
about calling oh look uh you know not to
bang her just to be one of those creepy
guys who just has calls up a hooker just
so she'll hang out and talk to him you
know
it's [__] ridiculous I don't know
anybody in this city anymore
I'm old I go on to the comedy clubs I
don't know anybody you know all the club
owners they either died or [__]
retired well they don't come in anymore
so I did the show I had a great time I'm
on this hi everybody take it easy see
you later then I walk out and I come
back to the hotel room by myself you
know that's depressing well yeah it is
so what do I do
what do I do to combat the loneliness
you know do I do something positive now
what do I do
I fight ordering a hooker to just talk
to and instead I go outside and I get to
mediocre slices of pizza and a pint of
ice cream because I figure that'll make
me feel better I'll tell you overrated
New York
city pizza all right and I'm gonna tell
you why not because it sucks it's
because everybody knows that it's
awesome so so many people jump on the
coattails of that who don't know how to
make pizza like you can't walk more than
a block and a half in New York without
finding a place that sells some pizza
you know and not all of it is good not
all of this [__] good look at this
[__] Matt Cassel all of a sudden
having a good game son of a [__] with
them [__] that I bet the charges for the
charges win tonight all right I'll go
two and two this weekend old Paul virzi
Pulver's he has already gone one in
three and I want you guys to send your
condolences out there and tell him you
know good luck for the rest of the
season because he is having an
absolutely [__] horrific year this
year and I'm not gonna lie to you I am
enjoying I'm enjoying it you know not
cuz I dislike the guy he just talks a
lot of [__] you know who talks [__]
about gambling
it's so [__] arbitrary you know did I
just use that word yeah I did
did I use it correctly I don't know seem
like you know I there's so many words
that I use that I've just heard them
used enough times that I can kind of use
them in a way that makes sense
arbitrary does that mean it's random it
doesn't mean that does it well why don't
you go look it up you [__] bookworm
you know I bet this stuff that I know
that you don't know so anyways yeah
tonight I got to do a Jimmy Fallon show
was [__] it was amazing it was a
milestone in my personal career in that
I did not have to do stand-up I actually
just got to go out and sit on the couch
which is a panel and it was fun man
Jimmy's cool as hell I know him from
back in the day and I don't know just
shot the [__] with them and then I went
off on gold-digging [__] and then that
was it
we got out of there and it seemed like
it went good cuz the band was laughing
that's always a good sign that's at
least that's how I gauge it i gauge it
on the band if you can make the ever
since that time I did I did a cruise
ship one time granted I ended up
fired cuz I started playing to the
[__] band but what was I supposed to
do play to all these old people out
there the goddamn booking agent if
you're listening you lied to me
you called me up you asked me to do a
cruise ship and I said you know I don't
really feel like I'm I don't think my
acts gonna fly on a cruise ship you know
isn't there a bunch of old people and
they're like this is what are they young
cool those cool uh you know cruise ships
because you know that's what all the
kids are doing I don't know if you guys
are old like me and you do wondering
what the kids are doing that's what
they're doing they're saving up their
money so they can go on a cruise that's
what they're doing so you know I show up
to this [__] cruise I've told this
story before right first person I see on
the boat is like this one hundred and
seven year old Vietnamese lady and she's
wearing that hat that they have on all
those Vietnam movies when they're out in
the rice paddies you know that thing it
looks like like a [__] I don't know
what you'd call it like a big bowl you'd
have on the center of your table and you
put fake fruit in it yeah it's like a
hat though and it's flattened out more
sort of like a trash can that you know
kind of has like a hat vibe right or
maybe like that thing underneath like a
potted plant that catches the water
except it's not as heavy you know
somewhere between that and newspaper is
it made out of bamboo wow what the [__]
it's made out of it she's wearing this
[__] and she's sound asleep with her
mouth open and she's missing from her
canines in on the uppers and lowers all
she has is her molars so immediately I'm
like well you know I guess if I was a
profession I'll be like doesn't matter
I'm gonna give my best show I'm gonna
put my best foot forward now I
immediately just said well [__] this you
know the only way I'm not bombing as if
this [__] ship sinks right now so I
went on stage you know followed this
juggler who was killing of course you
know juggling doing the whole [__]
thing
and then this guy smiley dude I told you
this story this is how old the crowd was
he came out and he goes if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands and they
did it right
that's like he might as well just gone
up there in the end going five foot two
eyes a blue but what those buds but
could do is anybody see my girl and they
all just jumped in you run into a 502
covered with pearls but could she'd love
could she woo
coochie-coochie-coochie-coo
sorry that was a song off my first album
I ever got told my parents I wanted a
record and did they go out and get me
Zeppelin did they get me ac/dc no they
got me sing along with Mitch Miller in
the gang and you know what I did I did
until I realized it causes you to get
the [__] kicked out of you at recess you
know do you know what that's like coming
out of the [__] cafeteria with bright
orange hair going won't you come home
Bill Bailey won't you come home come on
everybody roll out the barrel we'll have
a barrel of fun I'm trying to say I was
an outsider so anyways so I start
playing to the [__] band because all
these goddamn old people aren't laughing
so then I get defensive you know I was
like how many you guys you guys see that
movie Titanic and they all just stared
at me and a guy let me let me rephrase
that how many you people were on the
Titanic right and they all groan but
behind the curtain the band started
laughing so I just said [__] it I'm
playing - behind the curtain as I talked
to these [__] this cocoon test
audience that's out in front of me so
long story short I ended up getting
[__] I didn't get fired but I did not
get asked back and evidently the captain
wrote some letter to the agent I'm still
pissed that I never got it he said I was
offensive to all races he said I made
fun of the handicapped because I made
fun of midgets you know which I don't
consider them handicapped all right if
they're handicapped then so is a [__]
eight-year-old because they can both
reach the same amount of [__] you know
you know so if you're gonna use if you
gotta use that then is an eight-year-old
temporarily handicapped he's handicapped
but he's gonna grow out of it I don't
look at I don't look at little people as
being handicapped they're just shorter
than Danny DeVito see it was that kind
of silly [__] that you know all of a
sudden I'm like the worst person on the
[__] planet and I'm not okay to be on
the Carnival Cruise Line you know what a
great name for a [__] cruise right
y'all ready it's already bad enough it's
a cruise and then you have to add the
other bad genre of entertainment the
carnival and you put that in there look
at Tim Tebow having a rough game Tim
Tebow is the Danica Patrick of NFL
quarterbacks Oh would that Jesus Freak
kick the living [__] out of me if he
ever heard me say that he really is
though it's like the amount of [__]
attention that that guy gets just
because he's good-looking and he's into
the bearded baby right just can't get
enough of him oh he could just [__]
win a game the amount of jerseys we
could sell to those Jesus freaks cuz you
know what it is Jesus freaks they like
football too you know but you know they
don't they don't want to they don't want
to buy the Jersey if you're really into
the J star there you you don't want to
buy the jersey of some you know [__]
talking you know [__] [__] gold
chain wearing son of a [__] you don't
want that you want they they want the
clean cut you know they wanna they want
someone who like you know anytime
anything happens he thinks that he
thanks Jesus that's that's who they want
to buy the jersey of alright so
considering most athletes are doing what
you or I would do which is you'd buy a
flashy car get some jewelry and you go
bang some [__] why wouldn't you can
you imagine that if you were
professional football players you jacked
you have abs a zillion dollars in a
Lamborghini
you're telling me yeah I'm not gonna go
out and [__] some [__] I mean there's
literally something wrong with you if
you don't
you're out of your [__] mind and I
tell you if you don't and you go out and
you get married right out of the gate
you're gonna take that out on your wife
someday because she's not gonna
appreciate the fact that you didn't bang
those [__] you know she's gonna say
some dumb [__] like well you shouldn't
you just wanted to be with me she's not
gonna get it she's not gonna [__] get
it and she shouldn't get it cuz she
doesn't have a dick so she doesn't
understand what's going on she doesn't
understand the you know it's like your
dick is like calling in an air strike
you know every [__] two minutes it's
calling in the location or whatever
pussy's in the room right and what is
with this radio shack [__] sound I
got in the background I I don't care you
know I'm buying all new wires that's
it's going down all new wires next week
I'm redoing this like one of them Chip
Foose is [__] cars yeah it just call
it's calling in a [__] airstrike I'm
talking about Jesus Christ you know you
know the [__] debates I get into with
Paul virzi about Matt Cassel do you
member when Matt Cassell filled in for
Tom Brady and he went 11 and 5 and
everybody freaked the [__] out acting
like this guy was was a a level [__]
quarterback because nobody was smart
enough to realize that he took over an
18 and one team and one seven less
[__] games
somehow they couldn't do that math and
couldn't figure out that if he was it
just I don't know I don't want to get
[__] started with that okay why is
this [__] thing not sounding right
you know what
maybe the comedy will be that I'll sit
here and flip out being annoyed by my
own equipment even though I've been
listening to it gradually [__] the
bed for the last couple of weeks
whatever gives a [__] not making any
money off this thing and I'll start
caring when I make money what do you
guys think about that just like you guys
huh
you guys walking around picking up
litter for free I don't think so
hey uh let me hit let me ask you guys
opinion on this Tony LaRussa just
retired at what point should you stop
dyeing your hair you know I think it's
all right right into you like you're
like 50 but at some point if everybody
knows you dyeing your hair and then
especially if you face like his face the
guy looks you know oh wait he had like
shingles of some [__] I don't make fun
of people had diseases I just thought he
was old let's scratch all that god bless
him and his [__] Grecian formula by
the way do they make Grecian formula for
redheads you know and if they don't
we'll Spike Lee make a movie about that
about how I'm getting bamboozled does
anybody care about my plate exactly you
don't that's why I don't care about
yours that's why I make fun of fat
people I make fun of the ladies yeah I
don't give a [__] I don't I don't care
about your plate what do you think about
that well you shouldn't think anything
you know I don't have any [__] power
all right with 15 minutes in I think
this is going good so far
god I feel like [__] why did I eat those
two [__] slices of pizza and an
entire pint of [__] ice cream you
know what's funny is I was done with the
ice cream when I was halfway through the
pint but I'm in a room that doesn't have
any sort of refrigerator so I didn't
want it to go bad so I just child the
rest of it you know like that [__]
tub of [__] in seven wait all those
SpaghettiOs remember that that's what I
was doing if I was on The Biggest Loser
and I was one of those trainers I
wouldn't train him I just show him that
scene there's your future fatty and
there's the treadmill you make the
decision I'm gonna go over here and read
the paper
is so insensitive God it's not like you
don't have problems what about your
problems what if people reacted that way
to your problems would would you like it
so much of a sweet tooth I have this
lampshade looks like this [__] they put
inside one of those Boston uh [__]
eclairs
is it a Boston Eclair no it was a Boston
cream or a [__] he guy gives a [__]
who gives a [__] this goddamn Joe DeRosa
making me [__] work overtime let me
tell you how selfish that son of a
[__] it's unbelievable oh my god I
forgot to tell this story or an Opie and
Anthony today I crashed at de Rosa's
apartment Sunday night right so I'm
sleeping on the couch you know cuz I'm
[__] down-to-earth sleeping on the
couch and a thermal underneath my winter
jacket cuz that's how I do it that's how
I do it I don't give a [__] alright so
he goes and he sleeps in the bedroom
closes the door and he turns on the air
conditioning I don't know why I think
it's cuz he's half Egyptian and he's
used to being you know part of him is
used to living on the equator and it
just that doesn't make any sense it's
cold this time of year strike all that I
don't know what the [__] is deal is he's
got the [__] air conditioner on so
it's cranked so I wake up early to go to
Opie and Anthony and evidently he didn't
hear me get up and he forgot that I was
staying there so I just opened the door
and he's got like this [__] and the
ironing boards on the back of the door
so it all just sort of open was loud I
opened it he forgot it was there he
thought it was like an axe murder and he
completely freaked out and all he did
was he just started kicking his legs
underneath the underneath the sheets
that was a funny sparked his upper body
didn't move his lower legs were moving
like he would you know like when he do
the backstroke how your legs move like
like up and down up and down up and down
he was doing that underneath the sheets
with this
what the [__] looked on his face I gotta
tell you something I have not laughed
that hard at 7:15 in the morning
since back in the day when I would work
the Comedy Cellar mean Bobby Kelly and
Norton would stay up all night playing
chess or whatever and I would be coming
home like there's no [__] I will
never laughed that hard again without
staying up all night long it was almost
like hurt my like hurt my [__]
insides to laugh that hard so soon after
waking up I mean it was still dark out
and just watching this [__] I'll tell
you something if you ever want to kill
somebody and not have to worry about
getting scratched by the victim and
having your DNA under their fingernails
Joe DeRosa is the person you want to
kill because evidently
when he's faced with fight a flight his
entire upper body shuts down and he
kicks his legs like I don't know what
like he was I laugh so [__] hard at
him and as I go in the background all I
did was he rolled over on his side and
he gave me the finger and went back he
couldn't even defend himself oh Jesus
and there's my Joe DeRosa story when we
19 minutes in come on for [__] sakes
why the [__] would I bet there he goes
is he going down the field again Matt
Cassel looks great he looks [__]
great I'm not saying the guy's not a bad
quarterback okay I'm not saying that the
guy is not a good quarterback I'm just
saying you know what the [__] you take
over a team in the regular season that
goes 16 and oh all right you're driving
a Ferrari just keep it on the road and
then he goes 11 and 5 he loses five more
games but none of the fantasy football
playing jackasses can understand you
know because you're counting down from
16 all they're looking at is 11 and 5
makes the playoffs usually but we got
[__] that year but if you count down
that would be like if the Patriots went
11 and 5 then he would they would have
gone you know 6 and [__] 9 now 6 and
6 and 10 right would you consider that a
good good [__] turnaround that's
right Matt run off the field
I don't I don't dislike Matt I just want
Paul version to be wrong there you go
sack his [__] ass here come the
Chargers and fill up rap god damn shot
all I need you to do is cover I don't
give a [__] if you win or not
[__] it's 30 and 3 all right - singing
in a podcast anyway you guys are
literally sitting here listening to me
watch a game that's probably over by now
oh nice nice yeah let it go over your
[__] head you dumb [__] [__] idiot
the guy the ball is gonna land on the
25-yard line you're supposed to catch
that right it's not how it works you
football players past past a 20 you let
it roll into the end zone this [__]
guy let's Jesus Christ all right
whatever you know what's great is Paul
is doing so bad this year the worst that
can happen this week as I can tie him
and that's only because I missed two
weeks of football cuz I was overseas
that's my excuse
Paul virzi has no excuse all right let's
let's get into the let's get into the
the podcast questions here for the week
bill I was just listening to an old
podcast from 2008 and you had just
bought a set of training rings I haven't
heard you mention them in a while so I'm
just wondering where are they now and at
what point did you give up on being able
to do an Iron Cross go [__] yourself
interestingly enough you asked me what
happened to me Oh [__] sound in my
ear this is what happened I got in good
shape I really didn't have any place to
hang those things but what happened to
me as far as like that sort of strength
was I was at a Pirates game in 2008 I
tried to show off that I could [__]
bring my legs straight up and be in the
pike position and I did it without
stretching and I I don't know what I did
but the next day it felt like Freddy
Krueger had raked those knives down my
[__] stomach what is wrong with this
podcast come on see that's what I do
rather than boon buy new wires I yell at
the wires come on cut it out
so that's what happened was they were
able to do an Iron Cross no I wasn't and
you know what I hope that makes you feel
better about your life sir I know it
does did you fail the way I did with
whatever I said I was gonna do um
alright Zee Nazis we have a new topic Z
Nazis I was asking questions about from
people over in Europe I have not even
read this I'm gonna read a paragraph
somebody wrote about the Nazis there's
not much I'm flying by the seat of my
pants on this [__] podcast you can
barely hear Z Nazis hey Bill first of
all of the podcast was just listening to
what I believe is the latest podcast and
you were talking about I swear to god
I'm gonna [__] piece of [__] why
didn't I just go out and buy new wires I
mean how much would that [__] cost do
I need a whole new mixer wow this is
just pathetic you know how many [__]
shows okay you know what I'm just gonna
plow ahead here I was listening to the
podcast to what I believe is the latest
podcast and you were talking about these
situations some countries were in being
that they were basically in a
self-preservation situation you said
something along the lines of what is the
right move in that situation I thought I
would just tell you about this
documentary entitled the eleventh day
it's about when Hitler and the Germans
attempted to invade the island of Crete
in Greece basically what happens is that
the Greek army is already fighting
against the Nazis in other countries
so the Nazis are coming to invade and
there is no army there to defend the
people well what proceeds to happens is
a bunch of peasants including like old
men women children civilians basically
go down and greet the Nazis elite
paratroopers and proceed to begin to
kill them with farming tools and such
dude that's [__] awesome basically
it's a documentary about the power of
the human spirit and such as the Nazis
most elite paratroopers proceeded to get
scalped
Oh to get slapped around by a group of
ragtag women and children with farming
tools basically these people stand up
and say no it doesn't matter we will all
be executed and tortured we will fight
this evil bastard until the absolute end
the Germans start executing entire
villages of citizens by firing squad and
all this crazy horrible [__] but it only
increases the resistance by these
amazing people these people are the [__]
these people are like if this is all
true which why wouldn't it be
they're like the real-life action heroes
that all these guys pretend to be once
again the name of this documentary is
called the eleventh day if you just type
that into Google it's the first thing
that comes up I believe I would highly
recommend it to both you and anybody
who's interested in World War two
history and Hitler I'm not doing it
justice at all it's one of the most
amazing and emotional documents of ever
seeing my life happen they haven't made
a movie about this this is like making
me actually want to do some situps
work off this ice cream I'm like
inspired some of the people not to fight
the banks I just want to do something
vain I'm such a douche some of the
people from back then are still alive
and are interviewed including some of
the people leading the small resistant
groups that were hiding in the mountains
and then coming down occasionally to
ambush the Nazis or destroy their
airfields and stuff that's [__]
awesome um but let me ask you this but
did they get the full brunt of the the
Nazi army not to take away any sort of
credit I mean didn't they bring most of
that [__] to Germany
I meant Jeremy to bring it to England
see blitzkrieg yeah and then they were
also [__] it occupied France they
will fight in the [__] Russians they
went into Norway via [__] Sweden they
had some troops in Finland to fight off
the Russians up there man give me a [__]
they were all over the [__] place
but still I'm just saying good for them
good for them I'm actually gonna checked
out for that for those you have no
attention span like me it's called the
eleventh day all right let's get onto
dilemmas this week dilemmas
like my [__] wiring on the podcast
this week dilemmas bill if you had to
make the decision tomorrow between
becoming blind for the rest of your life
are losing your penis for the rest of
your life which one would you choose
I'll [__] you I'm really at the breaking
point with my dick you know what I mean
I mean I think my best years are behind
me but I still think I'm gonna see a lot
of cool [__] oh you [__] [__] [__]
blind for the rest never never again you
know some [__]
you know I think I'd have to choose oh
you know this is one of these things
where early on if you choose having your
dick
you'll be psyched that you kept your
dick but then when you're 80 and you
can't see you [__] wear your Geritol
is and your dick has been lifeless for
15 years it's gonna seem stupid so in
the long run having your eyes oh you
[__]
alright let's quit joking around I'm
gonna lose my penis you don't even mean
like it's not kind of work can at least
hang there you know and just not do
anything like some rusted-out car in the
front yard of some douches house or have
to completely lose it well losing your
penis for the rest of your life which
one would you choose I've got it I got a
good take out my eyes I got to go blind
because then you're also talking about
urinary tract infections and all that
shit's gonna be a [__] nightmare okay
you know I could still hear [__] I could
still do stand-up I know a rough time
with hecklers that I know you're over in
this general area I bet you have a
stupid shirt on yeah
I would choose my dick I'd have to
choose my dick alright would you rather
have sex with a man who used to be a
woman or a woman who used to be a man Oh
would you rather why are you guys gotta
have these creepy ones would you rather
have sex with a man who used to be a
woman I imagine it looked like what Chaz
Bono there's no [__] way I could do
that or a woman who used to be a woman
it used to be a man without a doubt it's
all the visual thing because that's at
least gonna look like a woman you know
why is everything gonna be about the
dick dude this is [__] hilarious this
is so written in by guys like I don't
know what women would write like would
you rather find true love or just have
this cream that makes your face look
young for the rest of your life
yeah I'm belittling women right now why
don't you guys write in a little more
all right but maybe because you're a
misogynistic [__] bill you ever think of
that nice point nice point by the ladies
all right number three bill watch your
we would you rather do watch your only
child die of cancer or find a cure by
sucking a dick well I don't have any
kids so I don't know what that love is
like but I've heard it's just whatever
you do it it's only one dick dad [__] it
I'd blow somebody well where would I go
mentally for that one Jesus Christ yeah
my kid has to live let me sit there and
have that hole in my heart for the rest
of my life you know that's the you know
what the dilemma is would you rather
have that hole in your heart of that
taste in your mouth oh my god yeah I'd
go with the dick and then just get a
[__] lifetime subscription to Altoids
all right
dilemma broccoli shirt or pineapple
pants I'd have to go with the broccoli
shirt I'd be worried that my dick would
go through the pineapple hole and I get
arrested
um we're worse maybe bees would land on
my nuts that was an easy one
number five bill would you rather give
up [__] forever me personally or get
I'm assuming you mean getting them or
give up cheese forever you can't have
anything that has cheese in it oh yeah
[__] cheese yeah dude that's easy [__]
that one I like that every once in a
while there's a nice nice [__]
softball that was an easy one if you had
to get blown by og G's which one Chaz
Bono or RuPaul see blow my brains out I
go Chaz Bono I go Chaz Bono for the
simple fact that Chaz would be just as
disgusted as I was the entertainment the
entertainment of that would be would all
would be worth it you know RuPaul would
just come in and be a douche and have
this [__] attitude and be walking
around like I actually found him sexy
and that would just annoy the [__]
[__] out of me but the fact that I could
bond with Chaz Bono that the fact that
neither one of us wanted to do it but
there was no way we had we could get out
of the out of the room you know oh my
god
Jesus we'd both need therapy after that
you know Wow all right easier all right
number seven bill would you rather go a
year without being able to wash your
hands I'll go a year without brushing
your teeth off without washing my hands
without a [__] doubt without a doubt
yeah no you can't let you [__] teeth
go you're out of your mind you let your
teeth go then you don't chew your food
right then it goes down
you stomach and big clumps then you have
stomach problems which leads to
intestinal problems with leads to
problem in your age it's all connected
it's all connected it's just your
[__] hands you know what am I gonna
do
I go year without uh you know and I
wouldn't help anybody with anything can
you give me a hand with this no no not
until [__] October 31st of 2012 go
[__] yourself
would you rather have a mouth that
opened and closed vertically instead of
horizontally or that doesn't make sense
your mouth opens and closes vertically
you mean my lips would I rather have my
lips vertically and I it opens and
closes like elevator doors I believe
that's what you mean or an ass that went
horizontally instead of vertically oh I
definitely take a weird-looking ass you
know I figure if you see that you
already like making me you know you're
gonna accept me for who I am at that
point if you're looking at my [__]
vertical ass dude it's not vertically an
ass that went horizontally instead of
vertically horizontally yeah you're
right I take that yeah who's gonna
notice dude you could go to the gym oh
you mean an ass crack you mean like
they're the [__] [__] Jesus cried
just I just make sure I always had the
gym towel around me back my way into the
to little kid show yeah I would
definitely take I take the weird-ass as
long as I could still run properly other
than that yeah the mouth I'm [__] I
wouldn't even have a chance
I wouldn't you know you don't know if
your face would be that [__] you
don't you have a chance I don't give a
[__] even chicks who are into scars then
I can that that's not gonna fly alright
advice hey Bill I need your help on this
my wife and I have been married for 18
months
about six months before we got married
all of her fun
out the window we used to do dinner
drinks fool around and you know all the
normal stuff but now it's it's pulling
teeth to get her to stop complaining and
have an ounce of fun she could she
claims this because of her birth control
giving her mood swings so four months
ago she got off it and no changes oh
because I was gonna say that could
happen cuz that stuff you know affects
women I obviously don't know how but
okay so she gets off of it for four
months and no changes how do I tell her
she might just be a [__] and need to
knock the Kent kunti [__] off um you
have to say that without calling or
don't have a don't ever go the
name-calling route first of all it's
disrespectful and then also it just
kills any sort of credibility that you
have you know what I mean that never
ever ever do the name-calling thing in a
relationship you know if you're if
you're you know yelling at some other
driver on the road that's when you break
out your [__] [__] you [__]
[__] but you never say that to the
person you're with it's disrespectful
and it also kills any sort of
credibility you have and what you have
to do is come at her not angry at all
and you have to just speak from the
heart that you know it's been four
months I haven't seen a change I don't
know if you have some sort of problem
with me but I you're I'm becoming
miserable in this relationship that gets
affecting my happiness the way you're
acting is affecting my happiness okay
and that shouldn't be what can we do to
fix it you have to come eat like there's
no way that's she can get and see what
you want to do when you have to convey
something as heavy as this you can't do
it with anger you can't do with
name-calling because your message gets
lost and then there's just gonna be a
bunch of name-calling back at you and
it's just but if you just calmly say it
that listen I'm not happy with the way
you're behaving and oh you [__]
interception nice
get on the ground get on the ground
there you go there you go nice alright
anyways the [__] was I talking about
yeah that's why you gotta tell us listen
you know you told me that it was it was
the birth control I believed you
so you got off to birth control it's
four months later and I haven't seen a
change and I am I am really not happy I
feel like you don't like me I feel like
you know I mean I'm projecting now I
don't know if this is what's going on
but like you know we have to do
something to fix this because I don't
want to be with somebody who's miserable
all the time you know what's your
problem you [__] [__] tonight you can
see you just got to think all right
underrated overrated underrated all
right
Wow I just discovered parsnips they're
like honey flavored carrots you know
I've had parsnips before and I still
don't know what the [__] they are how
the [__] have I never heard had these
delightful things before the recipes
online all seemed to be - all seem to -
involved so I just heated them by the
way too involved is T Oh Oh anytime he's
saying something's too much too many any
of that that's T oh oh the receipts the
recipes of receipts the recipes I
correct him I said read his receipts the
recipes online all seemed too involved
so I just heated them with a small
amount of butter and they were
tremendous parsnips everybody underrated
another underrated mature porn oh Jesus
my dad has gone through three wives they
kept getting younger and until the last
one decided to leave him looking at him
and worrying that I might take the same
route I decided to reprogram and only
jerk off to mature porn now I get down
with my wife
I'm bony hello now when I get down with
my wife on bone I feel like I'm boning
the hottest chick I know my friends
laugh
but it works Wow
you know what's crazy about that as
[__] up as that is like the math works
on that like I would think if you're
sitting around jerking off to old ladies
that all of a sudden if your wife came
in she's in her 30s 40s I mean she's
gonna look beautiful 50 she looked great
did mature porn Jesus overrated
getting wood when your mother-in-law is
taking the turkey out of the oven all
right we're gonna leave it at that I
don't know what the [__] happened there
what cuz she [__] bent over Wow
YouTube greatest scene ever committed to
film I didn't even get to watch this I
would love to see it but it's all gonna
be on the MM podcast.com and uh what the
[__] Philip come on come on guys put the
goddamn [__] ball in the end zone
I need seven here people I need seven
it's getting late in the game oh that's
nice there's a nice [__] hold why
don't you complain you know do it at see
that guy he's too down-to-earth now it's
fourth and six so now they got to go in
there and kick it how does that [__]
help me look at Ralph Burton irska comes
out guys like [__] 95 now and Kansas
City gave actually blocked two pas kicks
this year in baby the baby there we go
and baboom and he hits it alright 13 to
yeah keep shaking your heads Philip that
doesn't [__] help me you gotta yell
at the refs um alright that's I think
that's the podcast for this week right
when I'm all it's only 42 minutes what
the [__] am I talking about I can't do
that to you guys
holy [__] 42 minutes and I have already
blown through all the goddamn material
here now what am I gonna talk about huh
I don't know but I better think of
[__] 17 minutes worth the [__] here
goddamn that Joe DeRosa he completely
[__] me over I think he did it on
purpose he's really good with the
technology you know what I mean he's as
good with the technology as he is with
the ladies by the way is anybody out
there bought his CD the return of the
son of the depression auction evidently
it's some sort of clever reference to
Frank Zappa which is classic Joe you
know like if that was anybody else and
they did something that was that inside
I would give him [__] but what you gotta
understand is being a teen idol
sensation the only way you get to that
level is you're a child star at some
point in your life and your reality just
gets warped and that's what happened to
Joe you know he was left on a doorstep
outside of Philadelphia to this
unbelievably poverty stricken stricken
family they brought him in you know they
used to feed him breast milk through a
turkey baster anally and that affected
him you know it made him want to achieve
in life you know it wasn't like the
other kids who had a bun you know a
place to sleep Joe didn't have a place
to sleep Joe actually they used to make
him sleep on uneven boxes out in the
garage right near the tractor you know
he used to go to go to school and he had
like grass clippings in his hair and
they people teased him there's a
terrible upbringing and that's when he
had a dream and he used to rehearse
inside the the garage and next thing you
know he got he got his he got his first
he's got his first break when he was
like six years old he booked
guest star on Benson then after that
there was just something about him he
got the bug and he became his teen owl
sensation and you know got that taste of
fame developed a coke problem by the
time he was eight and now he's the
[__] up adult that you see and because
of that he does things like I asked him
to send me a [__] podcast and rather
than sending it in a form that I can
actually upload he'll blame me he'll
blame me the same way he did his first
26 managers and agents that he's had
this business I'm all fully fully
prepared for it you know Romeo Crennel
is on the [__] Kansas City Chiefs
Jesus Christ I got all the old Patriots
that stick up there you go first and ten
yeah now it's [__] second and
fourteen how you like that what happened
to the Chargers this year you know I was
talking to somebody about this [__] I
was talking about you know fighting my
older brother when I was younger and now
you know it got to the point at one
point we basically used to kick my ass
my old [__] life and at one point we
were kind of the same size right so
technically I could beat him but I just
couldn't like I would have the fights
won but I didn't know what to do I was
and I and I just basically Zack him nice
um now that coming on there you go I was
basically as far as fighting when I was
like the San Diego Chargers of fighting
you know I would I would have it won
with two minutes to go then somehow I
would [__] it up and I'm not being a
dick to charger fans and you have a
right to get mad at me because it's your
team so only fellow San Diego charger
fans I get it can trash your team it's
annoying when somebody like myself does
it but you know I'm right I don't know
what the [__] this team suffers from
they suffer for
oh my god we're actually gonna win it I
just tackle that [__] tackle him thank
you thank you
all right 4:30 left in the [__] third
quarter
that's a nice three and out there you go
Maddie you know Maddie iced down in
Atlanta Matt Cassel in Kansas City he's
Madi room temperature oh that was a [__]
joke I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't I got
13 more minutes to go I got 13 more
minutes to go and I got nothing you know
what I you know I actually that's not
true I don't have nothing I have I have
a a three night whirlwind tour of the
Midwest and I'll tell you nothing will
make you come down off the high of
traveling through the beauty of
Scandinavia like going to Cleveland Ohio
Madison Wisconsin and then st. Louis
Missouri now I know there's a lot of
people actually there's not a lot of
people that live in Cleveland you know
what's that zombies show on AMC what the
[__] is the name of that show you know
for some reason they shoot it in Atlanta
if and I know there was some sort of big
dispute about how much it costs for each
episode if anybody connected with that
show is listening you could cut your
costs tremendously if you just filmed
on-location in either Cleveland or
Detroit okay first of all all your night
scenes you wouldn't have to hire any
extras just have the people that come
out late at night
all right and I'm not talking about the
eight mile rapid movie I'm talking about
the [__] I saw dude I'm have a lot of
time driving through that city I don't
know what I did I was trying to go to a
[__] Red Wings game it was at night
it was in the winter I went down the
wrong Street I think no I'm ever I was
coming back from going to a Red Wings
game and I got off the wrong place and I
was trying to get on the highway I went
down a side street and there was a
[__] tree
had landed like across the street like
he could barely get up you could just
sort of drive around it and this thing
had been dead for months
like that's how [__] up that city is
so anyways but I'm not going there I'm
going to Cleveland I was there in April
by the way everybody keeps sending me
emails when you come into Detroit I was
there Royal Oak I'm gonna be at
Cleveland
Thursday night banished it was culture
Friday ever the pageant theater in st.
Louis and with that how about a round of
applause for the [__] st. Louis
candles they won another one Yankee fans
they're closing in on you
they got 11 you not so funny this is how
[__] kunti New York is when they
couldn't they could not give it up
they just can't give it up to anybody in
this city there's such [__] [__] st.
Louis you know when's the World Series
it's their eleventh championship they
have the most championships in the
National League it's their eleventh one
and what they write in the paper is the
Yankees won their eleventh dot dot dot
in 1947 you know I've never you know
even Boston with their [__] Laker
Celtic [__] we never said you know yo
you won your sixteenth we did that in
1986 it's really really [__] gay but
anyways they want it I'm psyched they
actually want it because now everybody's
gonna be happy when I go down there so
and I was actually thinking about this
st. Louis so they actually go you
[__] bastard go go go go go go go go
go go go down to the 35 nice you know
how much this is driving Paul virzi up
the [__] wall he goes one and three
and I go two and two you know I'm not a
[__] talker either cuz I know there's
there's no there's really no skill
involved in gambling there really is an
all you idiots who sitting there looking
at you know who's hurt who isn't how
this guy does on turf and this guy does
it isn't it's it's [__] the best
you're ever gonna do is win about 40% of
the [__] time so I'm hoping basically
I'm sitting here hoping to get lucky
again this week just to go to one too by
the way this this class is officially
over you guys are free to go
I'm gonna be uploading tomorrow if Joe
DeRosa the Corey Feldman of the the Opie
and Anthony program if he can actually
just send me the [__] podcast that we
did and I will upload it so technically
I guess I can end this thing is it
really should I really just keep going
with this [__] what the [__] can I talk
about oh whoa oh you're asking who was
the other guest I already know what's
gonna go on Heidi Klum was the other
guest on Jimmy Fallon so everybody would
you Joe did you talk to would you
[__] hook up with that no and no I
did see her she was absolutely just like
ridiculously good looking like her legs
alone were just like just stared at him
but not in like a a leering way you like
just like you just they were like from
another planet it was almost like like
if I don't know what like an alien
landed on this planet and in handed you
a [__] gadget you'd never seen before
it was they're [__] unbelievable and
I was just like Jesus Christ I'm ugly
that's all I was really thinking when I
was looking at her
this girl's [__]
I don't know anything about her she's
like she's like the kind of person that
gets married to like one of those guys
who like owns his own Island and has
like a hot-air balloon
you know that guy the winburn face the
guy that Donald Trump tries to be you
know what the [__] is that guy's name
you know Donald Trump hates that guy all
right he's got a full head of hair you
know he actually owns an island
he doesn't go bankrupt every [__] you
know time he opens a [__] casino like
if they had like a billionaire comedy
show like Donald Trump would be opening
for that guy the guy who owned Virgin
Airlines oh wait but he also owned
Virgin Records store I bet Donald Trump
was psyched when that thing went out of
business what the [__] am i target
nothing left [__] end zone please be
pass interference
please be passed there you go fill up
[__] complain a little bit works for
Tom Brady get in their faces Jesus
Christ you know what I should do I
should just end this [__] podcast and
just go walk like 20 blocks and try to
do something for the goddamn damage I
did my gut why would I do that to myself
you know is the worst who was a [__]
[__] didn't even heat up the [__]
slices properly the cheese one was okay
the other one you just you just [__]
it up what's wrong with me I don't know
what to do
you know what I'm just gonna keep doing
this podcast because you know what the
fucked-up thing is is most of you have
[__] you go for another [__] field
goal oh wait this would be 13 to 12 I'll
take this come on Ralph there you go 13
to 12
13 to 12 I love it I don't love it I
wanted a touchdown there anyways I'm
just gonna keep talking I'm gonna keep
talking till I go for a [__] hour all
right I got another six minutes not out
no that's using another seven minutes to
go I just want you to know right now how
pathetic your [__] life is if you
actually sit here and listen to the rest
of this and if you send me an email so
you know what to actually shut it off
now you didn't the fact that you still
took the time to email me and tell me
that you [__] listen to the rest of
this [__] oh you know dude there's no
[__] what is the point of this
exercise I can't go for it I got no
funny left I already did a podcast with
DeRosa
I did the Fallon show and now I did 50
[__] minutes okay
I've had enough I'm not answering the
bell I'm going out like a [__] [__]
hot and delicious pizza made just for
you I'm reading the pizza box at this
point that's it you know the worst part
about traveling to this amount of
[__] cities is is not enough time to
do your laundry so your outside pocket
on your [__] luggage just keeps
getting more and more [__] filled up
with dirty stinking underwears and with
that visual oh God you know I'm just
hanging on right now Mike my corner man
won't throw in the [__] towel I just
keep thinking that something else funny
is gonna come to me and I'm just I'm
tapped out I got nothing you guys are
still listening what is your [__]
morbid curiosity with this what do you
enjoy listening to me bomb in my own
podcast how about give me a little
credit for not hitting the [__] pause
button right now and maybe looking at a
couple of stories that to tackle that
[__] there you go there you go
[Music]
all right that's it I've had enough you
know what I'm just gonna declare victory
and go home just like we did in Vietnam
that's it our work is done here
can I stick it out for another three
minutes I don't know that I can't what
else do I got I got Carnegie Hall coming
up November 11th July of 2014 I'm
looking at playing an Air Force Base in
Mishawaka Wisconsin oh I know what I'll
make fun of you know what I have the
sound down right now no wonder I don't
have any [__] material I just saw Jon
Gruden and Ron Jaworski love both those
guys totally respect they have football
minds they know way more about sports
than I do but Jesus Christ is it me or
do they blow everybody every week I'll
tell you right now if you're into
quarterbacks you know if you don't like
this guy you don't like cornerbacks this
guy is one of the best I think this is
the greatest performance by a cornerback
we have ever seen would you say so just
absolutely I'll tell you if I was still
under center that's the kind of guy that
would keep me up at night just trying to
think of a way that I was gonna get that
ball in there thank God I had Wilbert
Montgomery to hand it off to look yuck
yuck yuck then they do the next [__]
play did you see that I'll tell you at
home that might look like a two-yard
gain off tackle but I'll tell you that's
some of the toughest six feet of real
estate you're ever gonna see that might
have been the greatest off tackle run I
have ever seen in my life
that's last year do you guys remember
when I went off on that when they were
flipping out about Michael Vick when he
was kicking the [__] out of the hapless
[__] Washington Redskins oh by the
way how'd you guys like that down in
Dallas how did you like your [__]
butt cheeks are still green from that
Eagle slamming in T as it was [__]
Tony Romo and he
I gotta be careful Security's gonna come
what a brutal beatdown my Patriots got
beaten congratulations to the Pittsburgh
Steelers I was in the air for most of
that game I've when I finally landed I
got to watch the last little bit of it
and everybody just said our secondary
look like [__] which they have kind of
all year but I have to admit like some
some days it's sometimes it's just not
you it's just not United and when I was
watching the Patriots like when they
threw a pass and it was a touchdown and
the refs missed it and so it took him
another three plays before they scored
you know not monumental but it still
killed like 40 30 40 critical [__]
seconds you know and then we go to do an
onside kick and we can't even execute
that like twice sometimes it's just not
unite Oh Polamalu slapped the ball
forward great [__] play not legal but
great [__] play and the refs don't
catch it somehow just sometimes it's not
unite and I got to tell you you know I
don't know what's going on with the
Pittsburgh Steeler New England Patriot
rivalry but I think it's more than
[__] up that the last three years in a
row we've played those [__] and it's
always in Pittsburgh was that basically
the deal you were gonna keep it in
Pittsburgh until they finally beat us
we're still six and two against you
during the Brady era but I know that
must have felt great to beat us you
[__] bastards why don't you guys grow
a dick down there in steel town you know
which it's not even steel town anymore
you're a bunch of pansies I've been
there where do you guys y'all down there
and your [__] cubicles looking at
spreadsheets that's what you're doing
all the real tough guys who built those
bridges they're gone they're gone not
because they died they're disgusted with
you updating your [__] goddamn
facebook status and playing fantasy
football you're a disgrace you know
drinking their beers in a hipster way
Pabst Blue Ribbon they drink that [__]
cuz that's all they could afford you
know they weren't drinking that in an
ironic way
huh what was the last time anybody under
the age of [__] 39 in Pittsburgh had
the balls to get up on a goddamn bridge
and replace a couple of rivets uh what
was the last time was the last time you
pushed away from that [__] desk they
bought it staples you know yawn did you
ty you rolled up the cuffs on your
[__] Dockers you went out there and
did a man's job when was the last time I
want to know you know that's why Cindy
Sidney Crosby
he's always flopping around on the ice
bitching all the time he learned that
from you guys the under 39 the under 39
years of age in Pittsburgh are an
absolute [__] disgrace those older
guys are the [__] the guys who put up
those bridges those guys whose
reputation you're riding the [__]
coattails on all you guys walking around
like you built a battleship you didn't
do that [__] I said they did in
Pittsburgh they built battleships that's
how badass they were they didn't do it
out in the ocean like those [__] on
the East Coast and down in San Diego
they built him right on the Allegheny
you know from day one the [__] thing
was touching the bottom of the river you
know what they did they [__] tied it
to Mike Webster and he walked right down
the [__] river until he came out to
the Baltimore Bay that's a true story
that's what people in Pittsburgh used to
do press so they used to do not now and
their [__] luxury boxes you know your
new ice capade castle where the [__]
Penguins are playing at what's wrong
with you Pittsburgh huh and your gay
little baseball park where you can see
the bridges and it looks like the end of
a Disney movie what happened to you guys
people used to go to Pittsburgh and they
were afraid you know what do you guys do
now huh beet drink
Pete's wicked ale what happened to you
it's funny somebody from Pittsburgh
actually listened to this and got angry
which makes me feel good could you beat
my team this week all right that's the
podcast for this week our in two minutes
that's it go [__] yourselves I'm
actually gonna have another one up when
Joe DeRosa you know
stops going through his Corey fee hits
the pipe every once in a while that's
one thing about Joe I've never seen a
guy write more material after freebasing
than he has
he's just it's phenomenal the way he's
able to function with the coke problem
that he has that's it that's that's the
podcast for this week this is part one
this is part one it's like Lord of the
Rings except there's only two parts and
I never even had any intention of
getting paid
unlike the director of that other one
that got completely [__] still 13 to
12:56 left to go oh god bill end it all
right see
you